>> Two beers please say
Word has it more
KREM please here.
Is that true.
You wouldn't happen
to be here now with the.
Better luck.
Next time Laredo.
>> Dismissed.
>> Rachel another double
ginger ale
with a splash
of cranberry juice.
>> Hi Mr. Cram I'm Sam.
>> Do they know I know
who you are.
We're friends on Facebook.
Oh you. You memorize
all your Facebook friends.
That wouldn't be
very good friend if I didn't.
Yeah. Well well.
>> Since we're friends
I don't mind telling you
I never miss a shot of the week.
>> If you consider doing a chump
with a day your lawsuits
would like me
to do it every hour.
But you know what
makes it special is the fact
that it's once a week
it's anticipation.
It's like flirting
is sometimes more fun than sex.
>> Yeah I miss sex though.
>> I like to Tucson but I just
enjoy heating it up first.
>> OH OH OH OH OH OH OH OH.
Mark we buy a drink.
Yeah you sure can.
And food too. Yeah bail me out.
Also order food.
Yeah having bagels up
for all of us.